okay before we get too far into this i
just need to say
the cheap looking button-down shirt and
tie office attire
i think loki looked cute in that
[Music]
loki episode two i just did two with two
hands it's not episodes episode two
the variant so we move forward and it
has
gone where i did a little bit of
predicting that it would go at least in
certain
elements i will hold off on that and i'm
for a little bit but i'm going to spend
a pretty decent amount of time talking
about
the thing towards the end
so before i get in there no i'm still
enjoying this
uh while there are some really neat
ideas and some
cool um presentations of stuff i'm
finding the overall
um progression of it fairly predictable
in terms of
plot beats so far but i do have hope
that it's going to start to
throw a few more curveballs and again
i'll explain why once i get a little bit
more into spoilers
but this is pretty much what you would
have expected the second episode to be
after that first episode set everything
up and set up the premise of loki
helping hunt down
a variant so it is loki and mobius
going to a couple of different points in
time trying to
well first of all just trying to figure
out how to even track down the variant
and then trying to actually
do that and just moving things along
that path
again with a few specific beats along
the way that i really do like
but it is basically what i expected it
to be
there wasn't really too much in the way
of outright surprise though like i said
a couple of clever things
which i would consider minor spoilers so
i guess this is your minor spoiler
warning where i talk about things sort
of
in the main body of it i'll give you the
majors for the warning before i get to
the stuff that happens
at the end so there's a there's a number
of things i really like about this i'm
gonna
freely say that you know
this other this variant that they're
hunting is another loki because that was
said at the end of the previous episode
so if you saw the previous episode
that's not even a spoiler at this point
i do like that during sort of the
briefing it gets established that there
have been
a lot of variant loki's there's a couple
of things i like about that
first is it establishes something that
actually makes
a ton of sense for a character like loki
which is that
he has stepped off his intended path a
lot and for the god of mischief
yeah that absolutely tracks and it sort
of makes things
more interesting for this loki because
if you stop and think about it for a
minute
that means that you know he was on his
intended path to a point
did all these other deviants that
they're talking about did they deviate
at
earlier points than he did at later
points than he did
you know how exactly that works it's
just interesting to start to think about
the other thing that it does in addition
to establishing the fact that loki
just as a character does this a lot
which tracks beautiful love it
and the other thing that it establishes
there are differences
with these variants sometimes as they
point out sometimes subtle
sometimes very significant differences
now part of that
is setting up stuff that goes on later
on in this very episode
um but also just in general it's fun to
like see the little differences like
there's this one logi that we could get
a quick view and he's like really
kind of hulked out and muscular is like
wait a minute
so like it was it was fun for a visual
gag for that as well
i love how loki
figures out well i love the both the
method by which
loki figures out um how this variant
version of himself is hiding and then i
love the explanation of how the hiding
is done
so i like that loki basically stumbles
across the answer
while trying to be on his own agenda
so you know he's going about trying to
gain
access to information that he is not
supposed to have
trying to get in touch with the
timekeepers which is not going to happen
and nobody wants him to be able to do
that
so he's going about and trying to
manipulate people and they pretty much
all got his number because they all know
how manipulative he
is for now very obvious reasons beside
the fact that they've got a whole file
on him
they've been dealing with versions of
him for a long time they're gonna know
the kind of stuff he tries to pull
um that said it does actually go pretty
well
for a hot minute in a few places where
loki
starts to deliver something like okay
he's making a point and i think i caught
on a little bit earlier than mobius did
where
you're like okay you're just you're just
trying to play this situation and get
what you want and
they realize it too which is good
because that means the other characters
aren't dumb one of the worst ways to
make
one character look smart is to just make
everybody else stupid
that's the lazy way to do it so i
appreciate that they didn't
go that road and instead are they're
having loki
have his trickery not work as well which
is kind of the issue he had
when trying to deal with thor thor knows
all his tricks
so him trying to keep on top of thor
through the usual means of deception
doesn't
work great because thor's used to it i
mean thor would try and give him the
benefit of the doubt now and then which
is probably something he shouldn't have
been doing but like
there it it limited loki's bag of tricks
and he's kind of dealing with that same
situation here with people who knows
what he
what he's about so i like that in the
process of trying to
subvert what he's supposed to be doing
you know trying to find out additional
information of
how this timeline was developed how it
started how it's supposed to end
what the sacred timeline actually is and
where it's going
and he's shut down at every point and he
said well what
information can i have access to and
he's just given his own file
and that's it now first of all despite
the fact that the
emotional high point of the last episode
was loki
seeing key events in his own timeline
that are
now not his own life they were what was
supposed to happen to him
um they managed to milk more of that
again because it didn't occur to me that
he didn't see that ragnarok fell
he saw that he stood with thor
he thought that he saw that he was kind
of welcome back welcomed back into that
fold
he saw that he died he didn't see
ragnarok
happen he didn't see asgard fall
and to have that hit him here
it was a good another way to sort of
ping that without having to sink as much
time into it as
was done last episode it's a bit more of
a callback an emotional callback
and i like that so um i like the path
that loki as a character goes on to get
to where
he gets the information that allows him
to figure out how this loki variant is
hiding
and i really like how the loki variant's
actually doing it
that cause that's the kind of thing that
that's a that's a little twist on time
travel that i really really
like um because i i don't
i don't remember if i said this last
time but i prefer
my time travel rules to be a little
looser
uh and have a little bit more wiggle
room because the instant you are locked
into
a um either a everything
has to happen a certain way no matter
what you do it will always happen that
way timeline
or into a uh
any change whatsoever has massive ripple
effects and therefore absolutely nothing
can be changed
sort of situation there's only so many
stories you can tell in those situations
and it's fairly limiting they can be
very well done but
they don't appeal to me as much because
there's not much freedom that's why i
tend to prefer something like doctor who
which has very loose
and oftentimes ill-defined rules and
does very well with them
or something like legends of tomorrow
where they establish like look
this thing happened and things are going
wrong but there is basically a window of
time before the new timeline is locked
in so if we can go there and
more or less put it back the way it was
it'll self-repair
it's this sort of loosey-goosey way of
dealing with it and i prefer that so i
like this idea here
that ultimately what the sacred timeline
cares about
is not each individual thing that
happens it cares about outcomes
it cares about actions that cause a
deviation from
major outcomes so if you go somewhere
like
pompeii on volcano day and
you know try not to run into the doctor
and donna then that means that
anything you can do there is basically
consequence-free
because it's all going to get wiped out
by the volcano anyway
so it's not a matter of every single
change every single little ripple causes
a butterfly effect it's like
no it only matters if it alters
major things later on and there are some
things in some circumstances
it actually does not matter what you do
and anything
like certain well anything you do in
that instance won't matter but it also
opens up the possibility
that certain things you do that maybe
aren't exactly what you were supposed to
be do
supposed to be doing might still be okay
as long as they don't alter
later events which gives a little wiggle
room on the notion
of free will which is also a
conversation i really like that loki has
with mobius
talking about free will and mobius kind
of being like well
no like there kind of is and it's not
clear and i kind of like that it's not
clear right now
whether mobius is faith in the
timekeepers and it's kind of
not being able to firmly explain how he
still kind of believes there is
at least a little bit of free will while
also believing in the
in the uh sacred timeline i like that
it's not clear right now whether he's
that way
because somewhere deep down he knows
there is no such thing as free will but
he doesn't he really doesn't want to
think about that
he doesn't want to think about how the
idea of free will doesn't gel with
everything else
or if he actually does just understand
things well enough that he understands
that there is
a little bit of wiggle room and free
will he just doesn't know how to explain
it
succinctly to loki which kind of will
put him in the same category as when the
doctor
doesn't really explain how things work
to uh to companions
because well it's way too complicated
just trust me i know
and i like that we can't tell that yet
now
if i'm going to make a certain amount of
predictions
first of all i'm reiterating what i said
which is that the time keepers
either never existed or don't exist now
because we keep building this idea that
people don't
see them mobius has never met them
that to me says that they are either a
fiction
and never existed at any point or if
they did
they are long since dead and this
whole thing is being done because they
said it was
it's what was supposed to happen but
they're not around to check with
anymore so maybe things changed
since they died but nobody is prepared
to challenge that idea
assuming they even know that's my guess
that's my prediction is that they are
just dead
uh or never existed i like that we get
the judge back
uh they name dropped her i cannot
remember it she is a character from the
comics
so that's kind of nice and i like that
they've set us at least
somebody who is above mobius that
he can push back against and sort of
make his case in favor of loki too
because
he kind of does need somebody like that
if we're not going gonna have the
timekeepers themselves judge is a good
call for that and i kind of like the
dynamic the two of them have i find it
interesting and entertaining to watch so
i like that she showed up and i'd be
happy to see more of her i kind of
expect we will especially considering we
saw her like grab something off
the mantel i'm like oh what's going on
there all right let's
uh let's get to the stuff that happens
at the end
all right so that's your major spoiler
warning
lady loki called it that said i would
not be surprised if we end up getting
more variants aside from just her
brought
into this that actually would make quite
a bit of sense especially considering
we've already seeded the idea that it's
not just two variants of loki i'd seen
some people predict already that richard
e grant who
has an undisclosed role in this is going
to be some version of loki like old loki
for lack of a better term which you know
would make sense and could be slotted
into this
now first thing i want to say say sofia
dimartino is an actress who i don't know
and i like that i don't know her i like
that they got somebody who
i mean i checked her imdb she's been
acting for a while so obviously she's
not like
a newbie but she hasn't been in really
mainstream stuff i actually
think i only recognize two things she's
been in and none of it's stuff that i've
ever seen before
so i like that we're getting a fresh
face into this world
because it could it would have been very
easy to stunt cass and i even saw
some people who agreed with me that lady
loki was going to show up
make that prediction i saw some people
say things like anne hathaway and i'm
like
i i like this idea much better i like
this idea much much more that it's
it's an actress that most audiences
aren't going to be familiar with
which makes the whole thing less
predictable because if you get a bigger
name
it feels like it well it feels like a
gimmick
for one thing and then the other thing
is is that it can also often feel
restrictive because if you get a really
big
name well my immediate thought is okay
this character's definitely not going to
live
to see the end of the series because
they would have to pay to keep bringing
this person
back unless unless she's going to show
up in the movies because maybe they'd
shell out that kind of money for what
with
with someone like uh this actress i
don't know
they could do anything they could do
absolutely anything with her
and i my brain isn't doing any of that
kind of calculations that it would have
been doing with someone who i recognized
um we don't get a ton of time with her
so i really don't get to see her do much
aside from play off of
tom hiddleston's loki the loki that we
know and i do enjoy that dynamic i like
her smugness i like that she seems to
have one up
on this loki and knows that um and how
much
that fact irks the loki that we know
i find it interesting that they put the
emphasis on sort of the
hypnotism enchantment kind of thing it
seems to be a little bit of a variant on
what loki was using the cosmic cube to
do
in avengers sort of uh take over people
but like a little bit different from
that because whereas loki could
basically
as long as he had control of the cube
take over people fairly completely and
quite a few of them
it seems like the way this works is
this loki can sort of almost directly
puppet somebody like even speak through
them but only one at a time and it's
something that has to be passed on
um from person to person so that's an
interesting twist
on that sort of possession and command
thing that we've seen loki do in the
past but this is a little bit different
and i do like that our loki um does
recognize it so it's something that he
is aware of and is familiar with oh
quick side note i love that he got all
pedantic about
uh what it was that his magic is and
that it wasn't
illusion it was i forget exactly what he
said but he's like no no it's this it's
different like i
i love that they paused to have that
conversation i had a lot of fun with
that
so her being here all right let's talk
about that
so this is relieving on at least one
level
because it means that the whole gender
or sorry
sex fluid thing that was in in loki's
dossier
wasn't lip service it wasn't just a
meaningless bone
being thrown to people who care about
the fact that loki in the comics and in
north
mythology is one of the few solid pieces
of representation for
gender or sexual fluidity in fiction
so i'm glad that it wasn't just a token
nod to it and they weren't actually
going to do something with it they have
now
done it now this still puts things in a
slightly odd place because
we don't know exactly how these variants
are created because like i said we don't
know at what point
she split off so we don't know if at
some point she was like our loki and
chose to change um gender or sex
we don't know if this is a loki you
broke off far far earlier than this loki
did and this was something that
she chose to do that this loki simply
isn't on a path to make a decision to do
they might never explore it and just
leave the idea of look it's a variant
it's gonna be different we're not gonna
explain why which i'd be a little bit
disappointed with but at least
wouldn't run the risk of like doing
something that comes across as
thoughtless and stupid so um
there is the inherent sort of issue that
um you know if if we take loki now
as a gender fluid or technically in this
sex fluid which isn't
quite so much a thing in reality but i'm
gonna say gender fluid let me just
let me have it um as a gender fluid
character there is the inherent issue of
well
loki's a deceiver both versions of
loki's are deceivers and manipulators
and dangerous but like that's baked into
the character
that's you know from the days of ancient
mythology so
i i i'm not going to be as hung up about
that as i would be with a character
being created from scratch
a brand new character who was
genderfluid and also
a deceiver and a trickster and evil
um so so far
cool i expected it to happen so far i'm
good with how it has happened
i will be really curious to see how much
more they choose
to or to not explain going forward
i here's the other thing um i said like
i
i felt like i knew where this was all
going up to this point and i really did
it
this was pretty much exactly what i
expected what i wasn't expecting
is for uh lady loki that's just what i'm
gonna call her right now
to do that much damage this early on
because what she does to basically just
send
a whole bunch of resets all across the
timeline to just cause
absolute chaos and create who knows how
many dozens
hundreds maybe even of variant timelines
that now suddenly the tva is going to
scramble to try and fix
and might not be able to before it's too
late
that's the kind of plan and the kind of
power move i would expect to happen
much later in the show like it's only a
six episode season so like maybe episode
four or four or five for that to happen
that should have been the thing that
like we knew she was trying to do but we
must stop her and oh no she did it now
we have to deal with that
she's pulled that off episode two so
even though i feel like i've i've
plotted this out pretty cleanly up to
this point
it's now hit a point where i don't know
what they're gonna do
exactly so they now have this loki he
followed her like
is he gonna join her we're probably
gonna find out her motivations which
will probably tie
into the timekeeper stuff but so there's
there's gonna be that and
we don't know really how much damage he
has done at this point
i don't feel like i can make other than
the timekeeper stuff that i said a ton
of predictions about what's going to
happen next
and that excites me i have enjoyed the
show up to this point but it has been
pretty much what i expected based off
trailers and this episode
was pretty much what i expected based
off the previous episode but now
i don't know what's going to happen and
i'm thrilled to find out what it is
loki episode 2 the variant what'd you
think whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
like share subscribe i have a patreon
almost pointing to the wrong side of the
screen i have a patreon
that is how i pay my bills rewards for
every tier of support i also have
youtube memberships
and if you are not able to do either of
those things don't worry about it like
share subscribe
they all help me out but even if you
can't do that
it's okay because at the end of the day
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye